welcome to bible question and answers my
name is jd quinn
if you're looking for answers to perhaps
some questions you've had for a long
time
you're at the right place pull up your
chair get comfortable we've got 12
questions that are going to be answered
some questions you've probably never
even thought of yourself
anyway we've got pastor john lo mccain
we've got pastor john denzin we have
jason bradley it's great to be here
good guys
hard-working guys
smart guys
and they've done their homework
anyway
let me get this
let me get this out of the way
if you have those questions that you've
wondered about for a long long time
i want you to give you how to get in
touch with us so that you can share
number one
if you want to text us
you can look at the bottom of your
tv
set there 618-228-3975
once again
618-228-3975
write your questions out
send it by phone
if you're going to do it by email email
is bible q a at 3abn.tv
once again
bible
q a
at
3abn.tv
and the third way
is for
i would say that
the younger crowd
instagram
at
there's a word for that at i just don't
know what it is but at 3abn
underscore official
once again at 3abn underscore official
that'll get those questions to us
and then
it goes to distribute among those
in our family
that are students
okay
i'm going to start with pastor john lo
mccain amen amen
number one question for pastor john are
the promises of jesus to the seven
churches specific or in general for all
overcomers of all ages
rudolph yeah okay before we dive into
our questions we're going to have prayer
together
amen loving father in heaven thank you
for the privilege and opportunity to
open your word we pray that you'll speak
to our hearts and minds we have
researched but we know that it is not by
might
nor by power but by your spirit we give
you our hearts and minds and may you be
glorified as we seek to comfort and
inform those whose questions have been
presented to us today and we ask this in
jesus name
amen amen
thank you thank you pastor yeah rudolph
that's a very good question i like that
are the promises of jesus to the seven
churches specific
or general for all overcomers in all
ages
now
i love that question because you answer
the question it's almost a rhetorical
question
yes in every age there are those who
need to overcome this is only one way to
overcome revelation 12 and verse 11 and
they overcame him by the blood of the
lamb and by the word of their testimony
but the answer is very very succinctly
and directly yes and i'll give you some
examples let's go to revelation
chapter one verse one to three
and we're going to talk about these
letters because there are seven letters
to the seven churches and then we find
this theme repeated throughout all the
letters
revelation 1 verse 1 to 3
the revelation of jesus christ which god
gave him
to show his servants
things which must shortly take place
and he sent and signified it by his
angel to his servant john
who bore witness to the word of god and
to the testimony of jesus christ
to all things that he saw
and here is the first blessing blessed
is he who reads and those who hear the
words of this prophecy and keeps those
things which are written in it for the
time is at hand one of the reasons why
that blessing was there in revelation 1
3 is because they didn't have multiple
copies of the bible like we have
nowadays so someone had the distinct
privilege of standing up unfolding the
scroll and the crowd listened to the pin
drop silence that they embraced as the
word of god was unfolded reminds me of
when people were
talk about russia before the curtains
went down
somebody talked about there was a bible
encased in glass and people would come
and stand in line just to copy what they
could from the page that was opened
how sacred and how beautiful it is but
the word of god is in fact
not only something that's for a specific
group of individuals however a specific
group of individuals benefit from it and
that are those who give their lives to
christ revelation 2 verse 7 we find this
phrase repeated seven times
in the book of revelation to him who
overcomes now the seven churches are are
not only churches in seven particular
times in history but seven conditions
that exist in churches in all of history
there are some who lost their first love
there are some who are part of a church
that has a name that's alive but they're
really dead they're those who are
lukewarm and and they they feel that
their goods
qualify them for having need of nothing
but they are nothing but wretched
miserable poor blind and naked
so revelation 21 verse 7
here's the promise that's very clear
he who overcomes shall inherit all
things and i will be his god and he
shall be my son and so yes the answer is
for all people in all ages the promises
of god are if you overcome you've got
some blessings that will follow
overcoming but you will never overcome
unless you overcome in the power and
righteousness of christ amen well well
put
pastor denzel
number one
will god forgive us no matter what we
have done and this is from sean in
jamaica
where god forgive us no matter what we
have done
so
let's go ahead and go to the scriptures
for this answer
uh i praised i praise the lord that
we can find in the bible wonderful
evidence about god's forgiveness
in 1st john chapter 1 verse 9 it says if
we confess our sins he is faithful and
just to forgive us for our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness no
exceptions are made there it doesn't say
if you kill 14 people i will not forgive
you if you kill one i will forgive you
but if you kill 14 i won't
yes god will forgive you no matter what
you've done but there is this
aspect of rebellion in which a person
wants to rebel against god knowing what
is
right to do and does wrong and pursues
that course of action
and
there is a confession of sin but not
repentance
not a sorrow and turning away from
so repentance includes sorrow for sin
and
a desire not to do those things again if
we confess our sins he is faithful and
just to forgive us for our sins and
cleanse us from all unrighteousness but
that includes repentance you want to be
forgiven you want to walk in the ways of
the lord and when you choose to walk in
the ways of the lord the lord can do his
part
because the wages of sin is death so if
you confess this sin
and then tomorrow you have plans to do
five six more uh you're not
you're not walking in the ways of the
lord you are just say well i need to i
need i need forgiveness for this and and
then you ask the lord to forgive you but
you do not have a change of a change of
course of action
then you are walking in rebellion you're
doing what you would call a habit
and so by god's grace when you say lord
forgive me is because you're receiving
the prompting of the holy spirit to say
i want to be forgiven i want to walk in
the ways of the lord and but you know
sometimes we're struggling with issues
issues that you're weak in this area
remember that it says in revelation not
revelation romans chapter 13 is it
romans chapter 13 no it's not that one
we'll find in a moment it says the sin
that does so easily beside us so some of
us because of habits we have formed and
because of hereditary tendencies we may
have a particular issue
that we fall into that sin but we don't
want to you know it's like
we we want to walk the right way we want
to walk the right way but
satan knows to push those buttons and we
fall into it and we want to be
we want to do the right thing we want to
do the right thing and we want to be
faithful
uh and we are learning the process of
depending on jesus learning the process
of understanding that jesus says in john
15 without me you can do nothing we're
learning that process
but
jesus you know we have to face each day
looking unto jesus the author and
finisher of our faith so it says in
first john chapter 2 verse 1 he says my
children these things i write unto you
the yeast and not but if any men sin we
have an advocate with the father jesus
christ the righteous and he is the
propitiation for our sins and not for
ours only but for the sins of the whole
world by god's grace we will be
victorious amen amen by the way that's
hebrews 12 hebrews 12 1. thank you very
much thank you thank you
jason this is one of your four-minute
questions
i'm an adventist since birth i know
right from wrong but because of the
power of choice i sometimes choose to do
wrong i know in my heart that after i
commit to sin i will feel bad and
confess but after a few days or months i
do the same thing over and over again
sometimes i even think in my heart to do
the sin anyway and just confess after
and i will be okay
have i already filled god's cup of wrath
against me so that he no longer will
listen to me
how will i know that god has not
abandoned me
yet despite this sinning repenting
repenting sinning scenario
will there still be room for forgiveness
that's from sam
that's a
that's a prevalent
attitude
among so many people
you know i i kind of wish that i could
verbally copy and paste some of pastor
denzie's answer into this one because i
feel like it really
fits the narrative here but sam the very
fact that you posed this question as
opposed to justifying your sinful
behavior as evidence of the holy spirit
working in your life and that god has
not
abandoned you
you haven't filled god's cup of wrath
against you so i want you to know that
but i do need to state that you are
playing a very very dangerous game
tomorrow's not promise our next minute's
not promised our next second is not
promised and so while you may
participate in this this behavior
willfully or willingly um and then have
plans of repenting
you don't know what's going to happen
and and it's it's an abuse of god's
mercy and his grace and we need to be
very cognizant of that uh i want to
share with you some good news though and
that can be found in first corinthians
chapter 10 verses 12 and 13. and before
i read this i i also want you to know
that we're all faced with temptation
so you're not you're not alone
with that we're all faced with
temptation but we can't yield to it
so first corinthians chapter 10 verses
12 and 13
therefore let him who thinks he stands
take heed lest he fall
no temptation has overtaken you except
such as is common to man but god is
faithful who will not allow you to be
tempted beyond what you are able but
with the temptation will also make the
way of escape that you may be able
to bear it
again we all make mistakes but it's
crucial that we get up and we repent and
we turn away
from our cherished sin
don't be discouraged and don't stay down
in proverbs chapter 24 verse 16 it says
for a righteous man may fall seven times
and rise again but the wicked shall fall
by calamity so get back up you have to
get back up and our works should be
evidence of our faith now notice i said
our works right because as pastor loma
kang says we are all saints under
construction
i've heard you say that on several
occasions i like that i like that it's
really really good
james chapter 2 verses 15 through 18
says if a brother or sister is naked and
destitute of daily food and one of you
says to them depart in peace be warmed
and filled but you do not give them the
things which are needed for the body
what does it profit
thus also faith by itself if it does not
have works is dead but someone will say
you have faith and i have works show me
your faith without your works and i will
show you my faith by my works
you know
you need to have some things in in place
right
you've been encountering these these
challenges in in your life you need to
have
some strategies in place you know what
is this cherished sin that you're
dealing with
where does this temptation lie where
does it does it stem from in your past
what at what point
basically what point are you tempted are
you placing yourself in tempted
tempting situations you need to kind of
take account of all of that
and have a strategy in place to avoid
placing yourself in those situations
where you know you're weak and where you
will fall
and
ask god this is this is the key ask god
to strengthen you to give you the
strength to overcome the snare that the
enemy has placed in your path
you can be an overcomer god desires a
solid
long lasting healthy relationship with
you
and
i just i just hope that you'll take them
up on amen amen very well put
it's
with his help
we can certainly accomplish that
okay pastor john
in revelation 16
verses 13 and 14 it says
and i saw three unclean spirits like
frogs coming out of the mouth of the
dragon
out of the mouth of the beast and out of
the mouth of the false prophet
for they are spirits of demons
performing signs which go out to the
kings of the earth and of the whole
world to gather them to the battle of
that great day of god almighty
according to the above verses
does the devil have an evil spirit in
him
and if so
does the word spirit refer to character
this is from makumbi
in uganda okay
thank you so much for that that's a very
good question and
when i think about this
this is a beautiful question that really
brings out a couple of things one
you ask does the devil have an evil
spirit with him you know ezekiel 28 and
isaiah 14 talks about
satan before his fall and what caused
his fall
and it talks about
iniquity was found in him
so we might ask the question how did
that get in him god didn't put it there
any more than god put a choice with
inside each of each one of us each of us
has what's called free moral agency but
to broaden the question after the fall
the bible talks about this in revelation
12 verse 7 to 9. let's look at that very
quickly
revelation 12 verse 7
and war broke out in heaven the war that
broke out in heaven was because of the
spirit that satan had within him the
spirit of rebellion
and bible says that rebellion
is as the sin of witchcraft we never
think about that when a person is in
rebellion that spirit is described as a
spirit of witchcraft witchcraft which is
a demonic spirit but the bible says war
broke out in heaven michael and his
angels fought with the dragon and the
dragon and his angels fought how did the
dragon get angels satan polluted one
third of the angels of heaven the bible
says in isaiah and in ezekiel by the
multitude of his trading he traded light
for darkness truth for error and he
peppered the minds that god and this is
amazing god didn't stop him
god doesn't prevent us from our
activities we will be victims of our own
choices in the midst of those activities
but it says
so the great dragon verse 9
was cast out that servant of old called
the devil and satan who deceives the
whole world he was cast to the earth and
his angels were cast out with him
now when the bible talks about that does
the devil have an evil spirit within him
he is the evil spirit
through his
evil spirits which are simply demons
revelation 16 you quote the passage
perfectly they are the spirits of demons
going out to the kings of the earth and
of the whole world these influences can
only impact someone who is not protected
by the spirit of god you know you have
in luke chapter 10 go there with me the
thought just came to my mind as i was
looking at luke 10 18
a beautiful passage here as i'm speaking
it was not one of my written down
scriptures but listen to this
luke 10 verse 18
i saw satan fall
like lightning from heaven verse 19
behold i give you authority over
authority to trample on serpents and
scorpions and over all the power of the
enemy and nothing shall by any means
hurt you why
because they are surrounded by the
spirit of god when you're surrounded by
the spirit of god you have on the whole
armor of god that you may be able to
quench the fiery darts of the wicked one
matthew 8 also talks about these evil
spirits matthew 8 verse 16
when evening had come
they brought to him many who were demon
possessed and he cast out the spirits
with a word and healed all who were sick
demon possessed there was a spirit that
was inside of them some people might say
well i'm not sure if that's epilepsy or
demon possession well some people have
medical conditions that predispose them
to certain behaviors but in the days of
christ these were demon-possessed people
and jesus healed and freed all of them
you also find in luke 1
chapter 8 and verse 2
and a certain woman who had been healed
of evil spirits and infirmities mary
called magdalene out of whom he had cast
seven demons
seven different occasions he cast a
demon out of mary when he was finally
when she was finally clean she became
the the poster child for the beauty of
the gospel wherever the gospel is
preached this woman's name would be
mentioned so
yes evil spirits and satan are
interchangeable does the devil have an
evil spirit within him yes the spirit of
rebellion
well very well put
johnny
why did lot offer his daughters to the
evil man of sodom in place of the angels
this seems to me just as evil and this
is from p
and the bay area california thank you so
much for that question we are now going
to genesis chapter 19 to see the
narrative there
why did lot do this this is a very good
question actually
so we remember that the angels went to
lot
and tried to and to get him and his
family out of there because god had
chosen to destroy sodom and gomorrah
because of all the iniquity there now
please understand that by this time god
had appealed to the people
over and over and over again and this is
the nature of the lord
remember nineveh the lord said jonah so
obviously at some point or another which
the bible does not record god has sent
offers of mercy to them to repent and
turn away and lot was supposed to be a
light to the community but as he
continued to live in that
those wicked cities in the wicked city
he became influenced by what was going
on and you can see the decision he was
he made at this point is obviously that
his uh
course of what is right and what is
wrong was becoming blurred in his mind
let's take a look at this
at this passage here begin it says uh
let's go to
genesis chapter 19
and verse 5 and they called unto lot and
said unto him where are the men which
came unto thee this night bring them out
unto us that we may know them this is
obviously a desire to have a sexual
intercourse with them they wanted to do
them harm
and so a lot went out it says in verse 6
at the door unto them and shut the door
after him
and said i pray you brethren do not so
wickedly
behold now i have two daughters which i
have not known man let me i pray you
bring them out unto you and do ye to
them as it is good in your eyes only
unto these men do nothing for therefore
came they under the shadow of my roof
and so the uh
the situation it was not something he
could control and they said stand back
and they said again this one fellow came
into sojourn and he will need to be a
judge
now will we deal worse with you than
with them obviously they wanted to do
him harm and they pressed sore upon the
man even lot and came near to break the
door but the men put forth their hand
that's the angels and pulled lot into
the house to them and shut the door so
obviously lot was going to suffer great
harm so why did lot offer his daughters
again righteousness and wickedness was
becoming blurred in his mind because
that's what happened
by beholding you become changed
observing the wickedness of the city he
began
to change and now he was making
decisions
that even brought his daughters into
harm and
at the right time the lord sent angels
to get them out of there but already the
seeds of wickedness were already in his
heart in his mind he was influenced to
offer his daughters which you know
you even today you would ask yourself
would i do that would i absolutely not
so this is obviously the corrupting
influence of sodom and gomorrah that
already was taking hold of uh
of lot and you can see later that his
daughters
uh they were also confused about what
was right and they took turns
making a lot drunk and having sexual
intercourse with him
with the wrong ideas so
this is what happens
it's amazing what a powerful word
corrupting influence corrupting
influence we have to be careful okay
jason
you're number two god spoke to me saying
quotes
once you are under my house and you are
under my rules i am god
was it god's voice
and this is from fabian
okay well let me go there real quick
here
uh fabian now i can't give you a
definitive answer as to you know whether
that was god speaking to you or not but
what i can tell you is that
god will never lead you contrary to his
word
so i i want to to point that out and
make that abundantly clear he will never
lead you contrary to his his word and
and to his will
let's look at romans chapter 8
verse 1 here
romans chapter 8 verse 1. and by the way
that sounds like a very parental type of
statement there
that once you are under my house you are
under my rules and there
there is a certain way that we we must
walk uh romans chapter eight verse one
there is therefore now no condemnation
to those who are in christ jesus who do
not walk according to the flesh but how
should we walk according to the spirit
right all right
third john chapter four let's go to
third john i mean third john not chapter
four verse four excuse me one chapter
and third john 3 john verse 4 i have no
greater joy than to hear that my
children walk in what they walk in truth
all right
so we are to walk in truth so now let's
look at john chapter 14
verse 15 and see
if we're in the house what rules we are
to keep and
usually when we're in someone's house we
love that individual so let's look at
john chapter 14 verse 15. if you love me
keep my what my commandments so if we
love the lord we should keep his
commandments and really therefore our
benefit so now let's look at john
chapter 13 verse 15.
for i have given you an example that you
should do as i have done to you
christ is our example
we need to follow him we're christians
we need to follow christ and and follow
his example and so we can't just be
hearers of the word we must be doers as
well so these are some some rules and
some principles that we must follow now
i also want us to look at luke chapter
6 verse 46
if i can get there ever so quickly here
luke chapter 6 verse 46
and that says
but why do you call me lord
and not do the things which i say
so
if we're calling ourselves christians we
need to do the things that christ is
instructing us to do as as simple as
that for the most part amen
amen
you pulled up good scripture there jason
i just want to take just a second
just a second here to give you a
reminder because i know there's people
that probably were sleeping during the
first part when i gave these uh how to
get in contact with us to submit their
questions so let's go back to the text
your text to submit your questions
618-228-3975
once again 6182
if you want to email
if you want to email that's bible qa at
3abn.tv
bible q a at 3abn.com
and instagram
is at 3abn
underscore
official
once again at 3abn underscore official
we got that out of the way and now let's
go to pastor john again
and uh
go for it let me see
according to luke 24 pastor john
according to luke 24 when jesus met with
his disciples after his resurrection
he
jesus ate boiled fish with them how do
we explain the fact that jesus ate dead
fish while in his glorified body
wow you really narrowed that question
down i love that
when i read this question i thought to
myself
he is in all aspects our example
the full context of the story is really
verses 37 to 43. let me read that for
you very quickly here because there was
a bigger picture here than a lot of
people they think it was a dietary act
but it was something far deeper than
that look at verse 37 of luke 24.
now jesus
is now
appearing in the midst of the disciples
but they were terrified and frightened
supposing that he
that
they had seen a
spirit okay now you have to get the
context they think that there's a spirit
showing up in the midst of them and he
said to them why are you troubled and
why
do doubts arise in your hearts behold my
hand and my feet
that this is i myself handle me and see
for a spirit does not have flesh and
bones as you see i have
verse 40 of luke chapter 24
when he had said this he showed them his
hands and his feet
but while they still did not believe for
joy and marveled he said to them
have you any food here
so they gave him a piece of boiled fish
and some honeycomb and he took it and
ate it in their presence okay so this is
a confirmation now
if i'm a spirit and i eat fish it's
gonna fall straight through the floor
if i am a spirit i can't eat anything
because i'm just a whispery kind of uh
apparition
this was a confirmation this was not a
dietary experience as much as jesus is
saying
you got anything here that's solid you
have anything here of substance and
knowing that amongst them were fishermen
he says give me something to eat and
they gave him a piece of boiled fish and
honeycomb and i can imagine those who
thought he was a spirit said let's see
if he could eat this
and he ate it and he swallowed it and he
says
now honestly do you now believe i'm
going to paraphrase do you not believe
that i am flesh and blood this is me in
the flesh you already pinched me and
later on doubting thomas he said put
your
just go ahead and look see the wound
here see the prince here
and and he said blessed are those who
have not seen and yet believe this was
really an act of confirming his divinity
in the flesh
after the resurrection this says a
couple of things
this debunks the idea that people that
are resurrected are resurrected in a
spirit form this debunks the idea that
after you die you enter into a spirit
form jesus debunked both of those he
went into the grave physically
came out of the grave physically and
glorified but the third thing that it
confirms is that there is nothing wrong
with eating clean fish when you read the
book of leviticus and deuteronomy you
find it very clear in leviticus 11 verse
12 whatever in the waters does not have
fins and scales that shall be an
abomination to you and i'm sure that
jesus did not eat unclean fish and the
fishermen who were the followers of
christ knew the difference so let's not
demonize fish fish are clean now today
it's quite different than the days of
christ watch out where you get your fish
from because there are all kinds of
things in the oceans nowadays but it was
simply a confirmation that he is not a
spirit but he in fact is resurrected in
the glorified body of the savior amen
amen
pastor denzel
where in the bible does it say that
there are varying degrees of punishment
for the wicked and especially since
punishment is usually metered out to
influence correction
that's sandra in huntsville alabama
thank you very much will sandra all
along the path of our life the lord
gives us warning signs of where our
sins are taking us and he tries to help
us and sometimes
something has to happen to us for us to
stop and reflect to understand that i
continue going this way i'm going to
experience harm now let's go to
galatians chapter 6 verse 7 i have
several scriptures to share with you be
not deceived god is not mocked for
whatsoever a man sold
that shall he also reap according to the
way you behave that's the way you will
be treated in us in shorter words i'm
gonna go quickly to a narrative in john
chapter five beginning in verse five and
a certain man was there which had an
infirmity thirty and eight years this
man had this infirmity because of sin
notice why when jesus saw him lie and
knew that he had been a long time in
that case he said unto him will you be
made whole
the impotent man said sir i have no man
when the water is troubled to put me
into the pool but while i am coming
another steps in before me jesus said to
him rise take up your bed and walk and
immediately the man was made whole and
took up his bed and walked and on the
same day was sabbath now notice verse 14
john 5 14 afterward jesus found him in
the temple and said to him behold you
are made whole sin no more lest a worse
thing come upon you so sin does bring
consequences
let's go quickly to luke chapter 12
verse 47 and 48 and that servant who
knew his master's will and did not
prepare himself or do according to his
will shall be beaten with many stripes
those are the ones that know what to do
and do not do them now notice verse 48
but he who did not know yet committed
things deserving of stripes shall be
beaten with few for every one
all to whom also
much is given from him much will be
required and to whom much has been
committed of him they will ask the more
the lord continues to call us to
repentance over and over again and he
has to allow
some trouble to come our way that we may
understand that we should
follow the lord and notice matthew
chapter 10 verse 14 and 15 and whoever
will not receive you nor hear your words
when you depart from that house or city
shake off the dust from your feet or
surely i say to you it will be more
tolerable
for the land of sodom and gomorrah in
the day of judgment than for that city
more tolerable this means that some
are having situations worse than others
there are degrees of punishment notice
hebrews chapter 10 verse 29 of how much
worse punishment do you suppose will he
be thought worthy who has trampled the
son of god under foot count
counted the blood of the covenant by
which he was sanctified a common thing
and insulted the spirit of grace so we
have here uh several scriptures that
help us understand there are degrees of
punishment and the lord in his mercy is
offering to everyone repentance and
forgiveness
amen
[Music]
okay jason
in the bible
especially in the old testament it talks
about wars multiple times in fact god
used to equip people to go to war let me
read that again
in the bible especially in the old
testament it talks about wars
multiple times
in fact god used to equip people to go
to war ephesians 6 says to girdle with
god's armor
based on god's word what's your opinion
about the wars that are happening all
over the world today
is it necessary and this is for
from iverka in canada okay virgo well
let's let's take a look at it you know
god never intended for mankind to
experience sin in in the first place but
he created us as free moral agents and
so
we have the choice whether or not we
serve him now when we go back to
creation to adam and eve when they were
in the garden and they ate the fruit and
then sin entered the world and then
later it was just a downward spiral so
death and murder and all of that stuff
was introduced
that was a very slippery slope if you
will um so god never intended for us to
experience
sin
so let's take a look at ephesians
chapter 6 as you mentioned i want us to
look at that chapter specifically verses
10 through 19 and let's look at the
armor that we're putting on and what the
message is here
finally my brethren be strong in the
lord and in the power of his might
put on the whole armor of god that you
may be able to stand against the wiles
of the devil
for we do not wrestle against flesh and
blood but against principalities against
powers against the rulers of the
darkness of this age
against spiritual hosts of wickedness in
the heavenly places therefore take up
the whole armor of god that you may be
able to withstand
in the evil day and having done all to
stand
stand there for having girded your waist
with truth so we're girding our waste
with truth having put on the breastplate
of righteousness
and having shod your feet with the
preparation of the gospel of peace
above all taking the shield of faith
with which you will be able to quench
all the fiery darts of the wicked one
and take the helmet of salvation and the
sword of the spirit which is the word of
god
which is the word of god praying always
with all prayer and supplication in the
spirit being watchful to this end with
all perseverance and supplication for
all the saints and for me
that utterance may be given to me that i
may open my mouth boldly to make known
the mystery of the gospel for which i am
an ambassador in chains that in it i may
speak boldly as i ought to speak
so as we can see from the words that are
used in these verses god is preparing us
for the spiritual warfare that we are
going to encounter this is what he is is
prepping us for you know and as
believers
the devil is after us i think you really
have to question things if the devil
isn't after you because that means that
you're more on his side if if he's not
trying to throw those fiery darts at you
and trip you up
so
take hold of these verses internalize
these verses and put on the armor of god
amen amen amen
okay pastor john
the bible says
if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive those sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness
first john 1 9.
your sins and iniquities i will remember
no more hebrews 8 12.
we're delivered from corruption and our
sins are cast behind his back isaiah 38
he will have compassion on us and cast
our sins into the depths of the sea
micah 7 19.
we read it and believe it but even all
of the safeguards taken why do these
sins keep coming back to haunt us
that's from paul and dot
in college dell tennessee okay you know
thank you for the question
as well as the scriptures that confirm
why you should not be allowing them to
come back
you quoted some beautiful scriptures
which are part of my answers uh it's not
the sin
that necessarily comes back it's the
remembrance
you know there are things called scars
and sometimes scars are physical scars
sometimes scars are emotional sometimes
scars are mental and we tend to
and there are some people that tend to
be more uh
hard on themselves than christ is
for example there's some people that
says i don't know how god could forgive
me after all that i've done i've had a
situation like that many years ago just
before i baptized my mother
that who abandoned me at three months
old left me at a babysitter and she says
after all i've done you actually forgave
me the first thing i did was i forgave
her and then before she got baptized how
could god really forgive me of all that
i've done to you and i said mom there's
nothing that you could do that god can't
forgive you of and i and my mom lived
long enough for me to baptize her in the
lord and she went to sleep in the lord
and so it's the memory of our past that
really haunts us that's why philippians
3 13 and i'm going to add another one to
it here's the key if you put it in the
lord's hands he says take my yoke for it
is easy and my burden it is light don't
you can't carry your own burden your
burdens will crush you if you try to
forgive yourself and then move on
without accepting the forgiveness of
christ which is complete and full and
lasting philippians 3 13
brethren
he says i do not count myself to have
apprehended i'm not already there yet
but one thing i do forgetting those
things which are say it together
behind and reaching forward to those
things which i'll wear ahead notice what
he does he didn't say i just dragged my
feet
he didn't say i'll get there eventually
he says i press
toward the goal or the prize for the
upward call of god in christ jesus now
why upward
because when you hit rock bottom there's
only one where you can go that's upward
and so many people are rock bottom but
they just prefer to look up to try to
find god rather than go up where god has
given them a direction to go go up from
here as the lord said to elijah what
does thou hear get up do something you
find jonah going down into the and all
the way down to the bottom of the ship
and they said lord had to get him out of
there so they threw him overboard what
shall we do unto you that peace may come
unto us the same thing applies to you
you've already quoted the scriptures
he's merciful he does not remember your
sins any longer he cast them in the
depths of the sea the former things
shall not be remembered sin shall not
rise up a second time and remember
whenever they come back to your mind
that may also be evil spirits trying to
impress on you and say you know you're
not all that
claim the promise of zechariah 3 2
the lord rebuke you satan the lord who
has chosen jerusalem rebuke you is this
not a brand pluck from the fire say
i am a brand plucked from the fire i'm
redeemed and forgiven by the blood of
the lamb
claim that and you'll believe it amen
wonderful
pastor denzi
this is your four-minute one
in genesis after cain killed abel
and was sent out of the garden of eden
he feared the people whom he would
encounter
who were these people and where did they
come from
this is my viewer in california
sometimes when you look into the
scriptures
the way the bible is
is written may confuse us and here in
genesis chapter 4 we're seeing that
adam and eve had cain and then abel was
born
and so the bible records those major
events and the lives of individuals
doesn't record the little things like
cain pulled the chair from under able
and he felt it doesn't record stuff like
that the major things that impact the
lives not only of the individuals but
the generations afterwards so adam and
eve had other sons besides cain and abel
this is obvious because in genesis
chapter 4 you see that
cain
knew his wife where did she come from
because the only options available is
that adam and eve had other sons and
daughters
and so the bible has to establish or
relate to us
why
cain is not mentioned after chapter four
because one of those sons of adam had to
be
uh the the firstborn uh aspect that
would be in the in the genealogy of
jesus
and seth is that individual let's look
at the scriptures in genesis chapter
four
uh
well in genesis chapter 4 word say we
have cain that he kills abel and genesis
chapter 4 verse 13
the lord had told him what was going to
happen to him and cain said to the lord
my punishment is greater than i can bear
surely you have driven me out of this
day from the face of the ground i shall
be hidden from your face i shall be a
fugitive and a vagabond and it shall
happen that anyone who finds me will
kill me so obviously he knew of others
in the family of adam now look at the
genealogy of cain
let's begin in genesis chapter 4 verse
16 then came went out from the presence
of the lord and dwelt in the land of not
on the east of eden and cain knew his
wife and she conceived and bore enoch
and he built the city and called the
name of the city after the name of his
son enoch so obviously
adam and eve had daughters and sons but
this is why cain was able to have a wife
and so uh you continue reading and it
tells you the genealogy to enoch was
born irad
or iran and begot mahu mahu
and mahu jail begat matusa
et cetera et cetera but notice then
when you go to genesis chapter 4 verse
25 and 26
and adam knew his wife again and she
bore a son and named himself for god has
appointed another seed for me instead of
abel who came killed seth becomes the
the
the firstborn aspect to be in the
genealogy of jesus notice seth and for
as for seth to him also a son was born
and he named him enosh and then men
began to call on the name of the lord
the genealogy of seth began to call on
the name of the lord genesis chapter 5
helps us
clarify all this genesis chapter 5 verse
1 2 and 3 this is the book of the
genealogy of adam in the day that god
created man he made him in the likeness
of god he created them male and female
and blessed them and called them mankind
in the day they were created
and adam lived
130 years 130 years surely he had other
sons and daughters
and begat a son in his own likeness in
his own image and named him sat so seth
was born when adam was 130 years
obviously there were other sons and
daughters by that time
and after he begats that
it says the days of adam were 800 years
and he began sons and daughters
so all the days that adam lived were 930
years and he died so we see 130 years is
when seth was born so obviously plenty
of time for other
sons and daughters of adam and eve to be
born
so this is where they came from
hey amen amen
okay jason
your fourth question
does malachi 310 apply to me totally or
partially
since i am now retired that's from jb in
brooklyn new york yes well jb is going
to answer it in west frankfort i guess
you retired before me congratulations
man amen but uh and in short malachi
chapter 3 verse 10 definitely applies to
you totally um but let's let's take a
look at that because
i've grown up i've gone to camp meetings
i've gone to churches i've heard this
verse so many times used uh before the
the offering so during the offer
how do you say photography thank you
so let's look at this
verse 10 of malachi chapter 3. bring all
the tithes into the storehouse that
there may be food in my house and try me
now in this says the lord of hosts if i
will not open for you the windows of
heaven and pour out for you such
blessing that there will not be room
enough to receive it
you know god loves a cheerful giver
if you look at second corinthians
chapter nine verses six and seven it
says but this i say
he who sows sparingly will also reap
sparingly and he who sows bountifully
will also reap bountifully
so let each one give as he purposes in
his heart not grudgingly or of necessity
for god loves
a cheerful giver and so
i want to respectfully flip this
question on you
and ask you do you want god to bless you
partially
or totally
amen oh wow okay i like that amen thank
you good i think that uh
that question is
issued to all of us
i know that my family for three
generations
we've been tithe givers and god has
certainly blessed us amen so
pastor john
you said something while ago we just got
51 seconds uh and then we picked this up
afterward i loved what you said while
ago
talking about
lots life
lots wife
[Music]
i'd like for you to pick that up here
uh
well when we come back from the news
break okay okay because i there's a
catch there that i think the people will
remember
okay so let's go to the news break
if you're enjoying our 3abn bible q a
then tell your friends each monday we'll
bring you a fresh program answering the
bible questions you send us using god's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bible
qa at 3abn.tv
that's bible qa at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975
[Music]
that's 618-228-3975
sure to include your name and where you
live and then watch three bible q a for
answers from god's word
okay pastor john let's go back now to
lot's wife
lots
life and wife okay gotcha it's a tongue
twister that's a tongue twister right
there well luke 17 32 and that's a
question that astropastor denzi answered
about that and the influence of sodom on
lot you know luke 17 32 very quickly
remember lot's wife and why remember
lot's wife instead of saying remember
and given her name is because the
influence of sodom you read in genesis
abraham gave him abram gave lot his
nephew a chance to choose which way he
goes and the bible says a lot lifted his
eyes genesis 13 10 so all the plain of
the jordan it was well watered
everywhere and
before the lord destroyed sodom and
gomorrah he chose that city and the
bible says but the men of sodom were
exceedingly wicked and sinful he knew
that when he entered the city you can't
go downtown any major city where it's
wicked and simple and say
why did i pick this city i better move
out of here he stayed there his family
his sons were destroyed his wife lost
her life on the way out and his
daughters were corrupted by the
influence of the city and he himself
made decisions while there in the city
that were corrupted
the lesson here is watch out where you
live
good uh corrupt
influencers
how's the bible say it
evil influences corrupt good manners
that's right and so we have to be very
very careful where we are because we
could be affected by the city and by the
surroundings
the people you choose often become the
destiny of your life amen any other word
yes you know it's interesting that even
though they noticed right away there was
wickedness but because they wanted to
prosper they stay there so be careful
where you choose to live because they
may determine what happens to you
as far as the decision of eternal life
or
wages of sin is death amen
i just want to say that you know it's so
important that we put on the armor of
god you know you see in sports you see
in all kinds of other areas of life
whether it's education and all of that
stuff
we put so much into it and work so hard
but in the eyes of eternity we need to
be preparing that much more and staying
focused on god's word amen
stay in focus
just want to say god bless each and
every one of you have a wonderful day in
him remember he is the creator god bless
[Music]
you